Hey youtubers it’s charlie, welcome to emergency
anime club 4.
This week we’ll be talking about our favorite
anime characters both good and bad.
I feel like a lot of lists I see are mostly
the good characters, but I always like the
evil characters too.
At least the ones that are written well.
Maybe that will be a theme for a future video.
Forever Evil.
Also a lot of you guys have been making some
great suggestions for future topics, please
keep it up.
Speaking of that let’s all give high fives
to winners of last week’s giveaway.
Congratulations to Commander Sloane, you win
the Crunchyroll figure and congratulations
to fanny martin.
You get to pick a future anime club topic.
I’ll message both of you on your channels
for details.
For this video I’m giving away an amazon
gift card for $20 and like usual a chance
to pick a future anime club episode.
Be sure to subscribe to participate.
So let’s get started, here’s my top 10
favorite anime characters.
Number 10 - Guts from beserk.
Easily one of the best swordsmen ever.
The lone warrior archetype has always been
a favorite of mine.
The story of his childhood is developed in
this incredible way and watching him become
a better fighter, largely without the aid
of magic is really cool.
I feel like it’s hard for non-magical characters
to compete but his story is so compelling.
Number 9 - Alucard from Hellsing.
He’s Dracula, and all my favorite vampire
stories are dracula stories.
But his fights are so much fun especially
with the addition of his taunts.
Plus you wouldn’t expect to see Dracula
fight with guns.
I’m also a big fan of the victorian outfit
and duster coat he wears.
Number 8 - Spike Spiegel from Cowboy Bebop.
He’s one of the best noir crime thriller
anime characters ever.
He has this casual nature that really misleads
you into thinking he’s soft.
But he’s one of the more violent characters
on my list.
Favorite Spike episode hands down is ballad
of fallen angels.
Number 7 - Levi from Attack On Titan.
Yes he’s overpowered, but he’s the best
fighter on the best new anime series in the
world right now.
He’s really the unsung hero of titan right
now.
At least in the world of the show.
The fandom gives him the credit he deserves.
I’m interested to see if they de-power him
a little in season 2 though.
Although it seems like everyone is secretly
a human form titan in disguise, so they may
not have to.
Number 6 - Totoro from Totoro.
He’s so ubiquitous around the world that
he became the avatar of studio ghibli.
So you could argue that he’s so awesome
he has to be in every movie they make.
At least in the logo.
I’m sure if you looked hard enough you could
find him drawn in a background frame in all
their subsequent films.
He’s like the R2D2 of anime.
The best mascott ever.
Number 5 - Kurapika from Hunter X Hunter 2011.
The red eyes of vengeance.
I love how
powerful the nen abilities made the character
and how they added all the restrictions to
keep it from getting ridiculous.
Favorite fight though was watching him go
all out with Uvogin.
The phantom troupe arc is a good one to revisit
if you ever want to jump back into the series.
Number 4 - Mikasa from Attack On Titan.
Eren might be the real protagonist of the
series, but Mikasa is the most identifiable.
Unless you count the titans.
She’s the the backbone of the ensemble.
She has to protect the person that has to
protect everyone.
For a long time I thought the show was secretly
about her.
Number 3 - Lust from FMA Brotherhood.
Favorite bad girl ever.
I definitely have a bias towards bad girls.
She has the benefit of being a major character
for pretty much the entire series and it was
so much fun watching her be downright evil,
then turn away from her mission and try so
badly to become human, just so she could die
permanently.
My favorite lust scene was definitely her
last scene.
Number 2 - Paprika from Paprika (2006) - She’s
like scarlett johansson’s character from
her, living in the world of inception and
the matrix trilogy.
She’s like the most epic digital avatar
in all of anime, so it’s only natural that
the characters of them film manifest her to
lead them through the digital dream world.
I guess you could argue that because dreams
and reality begin to merge, she is one of
the most powerful anime characters of all
time.
Number 1 - Edward Elric from FMA Brotherhood.
I should really include alphonse on this list
two, because the brothers really need to be
taken as a duo.
If it weren’t for the two of them I don’t
think Brotherhood would have been one of the
biggest anime shows on the planet.
The reason Edward and said brother are my
favorite are because their characters can
swing so easily from funny to sad, and from
warriors to scientists and from normal kids
to tragic heroes.
So as with all lists, there are a billion
awesome anime characters.
Be sure to let me know who your favorites
are in the comments.
I’m always looking for new characters to
knock some of these older ones off the list
and attack on titan has been the first in
a long time to do that.
I don’t totally know what next week’s
anime club is going to be yet, so leave me
your suggestions in the comments below.
Right now click here to for last week’s
anime club video and click here to learn all
about my walking dead countdown.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight,
high fives!